I'm writing a book right now and I have
three or four books that I'm writing in
my head that's how I write I'm called I
wish everybody was an immigrant it's a
huge advantage being a minority being an
underdog is an advantage I can't not
believe that most people come from
places that don't have as many
opportunities and like as my dad said he
was like try being Jewish in Russia
after the world war both my
grandfather's spent ten years in jail by
being Jewish straight up Wow
I am not talked to an immigrant that
doesn't have some level of disdain and
or disrespect for every American they
know by the way I think it's so good in
America that most people are soft I'm
making this for my son
Xander I think you're soft I think a lot
of you are not motivated because you're
luckier and what I mean by that is
you're lucky in different ways you
haven't dealt with the adversity that
much it's not a black-white thing girl
boy thing it's you just had great
parents you had a good upbringing like
life just didn't give you that much
adversity and so I don't know you like I
want to slice throats my mom and dad had
absolutely no no tolerance for
complaining there was no opportunity for
that I really appreciate that and it's
funny I'm visceral to complaining the
quickest tell that somebody's a loser is
complaining every kid every girl every
guy no matter your situation the one
thing you have is time and you can work
harder and maybe you got maybe mom and
dad didn't have a whole lot of talent
didn't pass that much town to you and
you're meant to be a C player at your
max but guess what it's better than
being a deep layer it's better than
being an F player and it's definitely
better than being a Z player there is
87% of the rest of the world where you
never have this chance and probably 0%
other place where it's so rewarded
I mean it's so rewarded even with all
the immigration and geopolitical issues
at hand still in America if you come
from another place even though you're
stealing our jobs and all the cliches
stuff that the hate and the negativity
that people are pushing still if you go
out and execute and win America is like
you're a winner it's really you know
it's capitalism yeah so yeah I think it
is a humongous advantage